[Music]
and DIY bachelorette news submitted by
Alison a woman Duke dozens of men into a
weird public tinder date whoo what so
there's no girls it's just a bunch of
guys that are like so what happen like
just it's her last hoorah relations I'm
about to get married I'm a bachelorette
so I'm I just know it's more of a show
Bachelorette you know how all the [ __ ]
no like oh they have a whole bunch of
guys trying to win level Oh cu
Bachelorette she's trying to make her
own like a DIY yeah it's a date gangbang
that's smart
[Music]
isn't that just every girl every day
like every girl in regular world is like
ten dudes like if you went through your
phone right and you just had a math test
I'm down to [ __ ] ten dudes we just call
I'm down I'm down I'm down I'm down
that's like every girl every day is the
black Bachelorette or just hottest
that's not bad that's just I want to
[ __ ] roulette or if you go hey I want a
relationship that's really I feel like
there's ten friendzone dudes that
immediately you know like isn't that the
truth for like girls I love this girls
know what other girls do you know I mean
like guys are stupid cuz we're talking
about a little older guys and we'll
still talk about it in front of other
girls guys like we have no idea that's
true I would say I have no idea when the
girls come together like we have no idea
what the [ __ ] they talking about
they're probably ruthless just cuz I've
heard other girls tell me that the like
you don't know how to start when the
girls are with each other oh well the
way we talk oh yeah the way we talk here
is how we just talk at general maybe you
guys are we're a little bit different
than the don't my girl what we're trying
to see you see a girl would say that so
that's hiding something like are you
like Shh
before you discover our secret yeah let
us know we don't know what those longer
closed doors I don't care he got
girlfriend all right so this girl her
name is Natasha she is a model and
actress pretty much she was hitting up
all these guys on tinder that she was
matching with having like really short
conversations with them like
I know no kind of like getting to know
them a bit but then if something then
she'll end up saying something like oh
you know what I'm really busy with work
I have this presentation I gotta do can
I hit you up in a few weeks when I'm
more free and then we could go fat like
get a drink or something and so all
these guys said yes and then oh because
then later on she did hit them that back
up and then invited them to Union Square
in New York at a certain time in a
certain day and said hey meet me in
front of the stage I have a friend
that's DJ let's see genus of DJing this
event that's where I'll meet you
so all these guys were waiting around
and it turned out to just be like one
huge ass weird like Hunger Games type of
tinder date where she had these guys
fight each other not fight but okay
doing like push-ups they were racing
like things like damn how hot is well
let me see what she looks exactly I
gotta see that [ __ ] she's gotta be
really hot for guys to go I'm down cuz
if she was average looking no not ever
issues below average they'd be like yeah
cuz if I went there and then she was
like oh by the way these other guys are
here do a push-up I'm like [ __ ] you ugly
that's why a lot of they're saying that
there were like about a hundred guys
there wow she's really hot so then she
started off with saint's like letting
everyone know like yeah you guys are all
here to try to win a date with me but
first of all she started doing
elimination she get the event sponsored
by Reebok it's like her own CrossFit
Games it was crazy
no so she started doing these
elimination she was like blah
statistically proven that half of the
people here are in relationships cuz if
you're on a dating app that means you're
in a relationship whatever so she's like
if you are then leave now if you're bald
leave now if you're shorter than five
why does she even invite them leave now
imagine a guy doing this oh yeah it
would be terrible if you're if you're
this this you're fat if your waist is
above this leave now if you complain
leave now
PMS leave now I think the guy can't even
get this I know really
hey no I mean you guys are thinking like
this cuz you guys are average looking if
you guys were fine
nope did you see what happened to that
guy that had that mug shot he commited a
[ __ ] crime and women no more
proposals fine fine that was pretty fine
yeah all right how much you want to bet
this [ __ ] isn't near as good-looking as
that guy
absolutely I agree cuz guys are done
I'll bet you she's really hot
because tip I can show this yet TIFF
Charlotte yeah she's trying to make us
go oh wow but guys will still hit that
absolutely not so let me tell you the
other eliminations and then I'll show
you cuz then as soon as I show you what
she looks like you're not listening we
lost her why so then she said if you can
support Trump and data puerto recan now
it's time to leave if you're if anyone
is a tourist or doesn't live in this
country you should leave to anyone named
Jimmy
you should leave I don't like the name
Jimmy that's a pretty sorry name
men with beer bellies long beards khakis
and TOMS shoes
Wow damn she knows what she wants go
girl
yeah so she was like I am single yeah
yeah she's like I am single I am trying
to get a date whatever it 'smoke on now
I'll show you what she looks like
Natasha no I see I see another one
that's not good enough that's a bad
picture that's a bad picture it's a
pretty bad picture she's got boobs oh
those are two different girls what yeah
but she ain't that good-looking though
she's she's but she did she could get
away with what she's doing no she did
she got away with it you can't put pants
on the the livestock that's yeah what is
the cattle look like yeah
but we know what its gonna look like it
was just a very diverse crowd oh I'm
looking at her right now yeah yeah
they're all like yeah it's pretty
diverse
well like see great dudes well what a
great dude goes on these apps cuz they
can get back with theirs so then they're
saying that this whole thing was a
marketing scheme it was by the same
people that did that whole walking yeah
calling but that's still amazing the
marketing scheme or not they were able
to pull it off without people that were
applying for it knowing that it was a
marketing thing and they stayed there
and they [ __ ] dealt with her how can
we defeat oh yeah that's crazy you know
how thirsty dudes are yeah I dunno that
sucks that Dickies is such a low demand
and the fact that there was a hundred
guys she probably went for the guys that
are really even if she's like the
hottest girl on earth if I showed up and
there's a hundred other guys I'm like
for a date [ __ ] no could then like even
if you do win right you have to spend
money and [ __ ] talk to her and
[ __ ] win again
well what I think of relationships about
though no no that's like you [ __ ] first
and then you figure out if you like the
person or not to stick around that's
what happens and then you find out damn
dude we can [ __ ] make it cuz it's
everything before that is just a [ __ ]
lie you know what I'm like I agree with
all that you need to get along with
everybody but like sex is so important
to me right yeah it really is in most
guys I'll say this right now like most
guys they court women to have sex
they lie and say like yeah man I just
want to love and all this stuff
bull [ __ ] you want to get laid and also
do want those things cuz that makes a
sexy mother that's a hundred percent
true but the thing is a lot of guys lie
to themselves to convince themselves
that they are in love with the woman
when they're totally not right for each
other
when they're totally you know ii mean
like that's like just immature people
exactly exactly but then I mean I'm not
knocking on the fact of like people
wanting relationships in love I'm saying
that a lot of guys don't know themselves
and they say and they convince
themselves that hey I'm dating this girl
yeah we're like so meant for each other
and all this
and it's like what are you talking about
do you have nothing in common but it's
because they look good or you just want
to get laid so bad that you convinced
yourself yeah Elon Musk and Grimes
exactly you I don't know how that worked
I look that good either
that's not billionaire [ __ ] I know I've
been after Amber Heard he went that's
rich nerd [ __ ]
she's dangerous [ __ ] off tangent
fetishes you don't know what's going on
derivative fetishes that's him
he's probably like God what's her real
name then oh Claire Claire Claire is one
of my favorite doughnuts and somehow we
brought it back to food David's like 40
pounds lighter the Inside Man oh yeah so
the marketing company I put all this
together the only thing that they've
said so far because they are creating a
video there were cameras at the event
they are creating a video that's coming
out later on today as of now they've
said that all they can say is that this
project slash video is about gender
dating and Technology issues and the
absurdity of modern /at dating that's
what is this gonna like rip on men
though I feel like that's kind of the
thing right now ripping up not all men
are rapists and all men are crazy
Oh since they did the catcalling thing
before I think it's very just right now
it's very different
everything's divisive like in politics
and everything even like men and women
like we're not supposed to be a team
anymore everything is like us against
you and just [ __ ] who's got that more
twisted than that it's like we're not a
team we should be a team but by them
going off of that like it's splitting it
even more I heard it saw device of your
eyes aren't supposed to go in the same
direction it starts going like this Joe
he couldn't get through man you've been
holding on to that saying as I think
should devote
I want to be divisive I pictured a
catfish there's just like a gap in your
teeth that starts to form you should
[ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm out humans face is
just a wall look even our left and rolla
brains trying to [ __ ] split geckos
and [ __ ] and fish everyone's a conjoined
twin
[Music]